history offers many definitions of what
it takes to be a great leader and you
will forged in crisis the power of
courageous leadership in turbulent times
examines the lives successes and
failures of five historical leaders
written by harvard business school
historian nancy kane and looks at polar
explorer ernest shackleton who attempted
to travel to Antarctica in 1914 the 16th
President of the United States Abraham
Lincoln and abolitionist social reformer
and writer Frederick Douglass Kane also
writes about German pastor dietrich
bonheoffer he died in the fight against
the Nazi dictatorship and scientist
Rachel Carson the only woman in the
group Nancy Carson looked at the dangers
of pesticide and she's credited with
advancing the environmental movement
fortune crisis is published we should
tell you by a Scribner that's an imprint
of Simon & Schuster which is a division
of CBS we welcome McCain to the table
not because of the ties but because this
is a really good book because you
welcome god bless you god bless you too
you said all of these leaders are made
not born what I thought was interesting
they all faced a crisis and they went
through it but start with the leaders
are made not born they're made and
they're made in a way that begins often
it was some kind of adversity and the
second piece that's really important is
in the middle of the perfect storm they
say I'm gonna make something good of all
these high winds and big waves but the
third component which is really
important is that they they find or
stumble into a big worthy honorable
mission and the last piece of the making
and this is really important for leaders
today as they summon up and and nurture
great stores of emotional awareness and
discipline they face the crisis and they
walk through it and embrace it
absolutely Gail let's start first with
the Explorer Ernest Shackleton who was a
attempted to be the first to travel to
the South Pole what are the lessons from
him one lesson that Ernest Shackleton
learns and that's very important today
is that we all eyes are on leaders so
how they show up how they carry
themselves whether they look confident
whether that how they treat people what
eye contact they make are things that
people are taking cues from you said
they feed off of your energy as a leader
absolutely because everything you do
absolutely in one of
important thing Shackleton has to do is
to manage the energy of these 27 men to
keep them away from the cliff of doubt
and despair and discord and and that is
a critically important message and
lesson for leaders leaving all of us
through our own turbulence and all these
crises that our nation is facing yeah
about Frederick Douglass so Frederick
Douglass I think learns a whole series
of lessons the most important of which
is you need to leaders have to learn to
step into the fear to take the first
step and move into their anxiety and
then discover in that movement the
strength and the power that they have
the resilience that they have within
them is relevant today Nancy because at
one point you said in the book sometimes
it's best to do nothing well I think
this is a terribly important lesson
right now all these leaders learned that
when the emotional stakes are high when
the big issues are at hand best not to
do anything because we don't make our
best decisions in the heat of the
emotional intensity best to wait
practice some discipline and not
sabotage our mission by saying or doing
or discouraging something that's
destructive you also say that leaders
are often lonely even the best leaders
that finds where they're lonely and
depressed you said absolutely that was
one of the most interesting things about
doing the research each of these people
struggle through dark nights of the soul
when they don't know what to do they
want to give up and and they're really
confused and yet by a hair's breadth
none of them does and that has made all
the difference especially draw Abraham
Lincoln absolutely Charlie I mean he has
you know well know he had deep dark
moments when he thought he couldn't go
on right he couldn't keep the Union
together and if he had given up the
course of world history would have been
different but he did not thank you for
coming yeah thank you for having all
these leaders have still have continued
impact on the world I thought that that
was an important point
forged in crisis is on sale now